stop the car that's definitely me when I
see a good sushi place on the side of
the road welcome back to things you
missed today we're looking at the
trailer for the zombie film cargo it's
based off a 2013 short film of the same
name and the two directors of the short
are back to handle the feature I love to
see that so let's check out some things
you missed if you haven't seen the short
it's pretty simple dad wakes up in a car
crash mom is a zombie daughter is
perfectly fine the dad then realizes
he's been bit and devises a contraption
to keep his daughter safe until someone
can find them obviously you can't make a
full feature off of that so I'm gonna be
talking about what was added and what
was changed as well based on these
opening shots it seems that the couple
is living on a houseboat which when it
comes to a zombie apocalypse is a good
idea for safety but isn't really
sustainable because you will run out of
food and have to go back on land to get
more and I'm guessing that's what
happens here because a satellite dish
wouldn't work on a boat so they must be
on land when something gets on to their
boat my guess is whatever happened to
these guys happens to the mom something
gets in the boat and gets her infected
they must decide to take the land to go
find help
before her 48 hours were up and that
sets the stage for where the original
short film begins with the car crash but
before we go on from there there's one
thing you might have looked past which
is all these soldiers with their heads
buried in the ground that tells me a
couple things first that were a little
bit further into this apocalypse because
the army had already fought and
presumably lost the short seems to take
place right at the started the
apocalypse given that he put his
daughter in the backpack for some humans
to find them so it's got to be mostly
still humans at this point second thing
that the shot tells me is that the only
dead people we see in the trailer who
aren't walking around in zombies have
their heads buried like this so maybe
this is some kind of trap set by humans
like maybe there's some yummy meat down
there and the zombies get stuff like
that until someone comes along and kills
them off I know if someone puts some
fancy tuna at home I'd be climbing down
there to go get it let me know what your
thoughts on the Buried heads are in the
comments though next I want to look at
the zombies themselves we see that their
eyes are glazed over and they have this
yellow green mould over their skin if I
had to guess I'd say that points to this
being a viral
infection this is the point where the
dad realizes that he's going to be
infected too and has to find someone to
care for Rosie so he sets off on foot
and comes across a village that seems to
have electricity
thanks to these solar-powered lights
there's a quick shot here of this
balloon in the short he ties a balloon
to himself to increase his visibility
and entertain the baby so this could be
a little reference to that I think the
tribal kid he meets is an Aboriginal
Australian native so this picture of the
rival from Pokemon silver a Rick and
Morty character named Willy and jeffrey
tambor might actually be the family with
the kid the dad and this might be the
shaman of their village who could be
significant if he possesses some kind of
healing remedy this kid is not present
in the short film and looks to be a
major part of this feature my guess is
that this kid is introduced into the pot
as kind of a gauge for the main guys
character development when they first
meet the kids father has already turned
and the main character's advice is to
let go that wall got any more but I
think he's the one who's gonna have to
learn how hard it is to let go of a
loved one even if it's for the best and
this will be his main obstacle in the
movie the film's title Targo has not
changed from the short film but I do
think it takes on a second meaning here
originally the baby it rosy is the cargo
he's trying to transport her to safety
and that's still true but I also noticed
that the survivor camp they come across
is filled with these cargo storage units
I'm guessing that they sleep in these
things for protection at night so not
only is the baby the cargo but everyone
in that survivor camp is considered
cargo and my last thing you miss for
this trailer is something I'd like to
open a discussion about in the comments
the Aboriginal kids dad has this G
symbol on his clothing and the sniper
later on at the survivor camp has the
same symbol on his hat so what do you
think the meaning is behind that is
there some kind of connection between
these characters if you're looking
forward to seeing where they take this
movie give this video a like I think the
next things you missed I'm gonna do is a
quiet place so make sure you subscribe
[Music]
so you don't miss that and I'll see you
in the next line assuming we both
survive